hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV I am at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas with one of
the most Freedom Fest tastic Lawyers in
America I just did that Randy Barnett
thank you so much for joining us Randy
Barnett is affiliated with Georgetown
University he is widely credit with
being with sort of the intellectual
brains behind the challenge to Obamacare
a couple of years back just wrote a
piece though this morning in the Wall
Street Journal I've just been told by
reliable source having to do with NSA
surveillance and whatnot what's the OP
upshot of all that yeah I mean the issue
is whether it's constitutional for the
federal government to seize vast
quantities blanket quantities of private
data from private companies we're
normally accustomed to thinking of
search and seizure so first you get a
warrant to search then you seize what
you find but what we have here is
blanket seizure before we do any
searches and so first the government
seizes all of these databases and then
file using data mining they then get
probable cause for their later search
but the question is whether a blanket
search just like general warrants used
to be at the Revolutionary times whether
a blanket search is constitutional or
not so that's one of the big problems
that we need to think very hard about
the other major problem is simply the
secrecy of the programs we have supposed
to have a republican form of government
and that means that the people
ultimately are the check on governmental
power but the people can't check
governmental power if they don't know
what the government is up to even if
some special intelligence committee
knows what's up the people don't know
what's up and we didn't know it was up
until these illegal leaks happen and
that's how we found out so there is a
real fundamental challenge to having
popular sovereignty if the people can't
know that the government is collecting
data on them and by confiscating it from
private companies hasn't the court
system to the Supreme Court been
ratifying these kind of fake oversight
like we're oversight by you know one
judge over here in this room who can't
really know what's going on from the
executive well it's in this case it's
even worse which is the other part of
the piece I had this morning and that is
we have a secret court the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court who who
is author who is
in place basically to authorize secret
search warrants which is not all that
unusual because judges usually authorize
warrants what they say ex parte that is
there's no it's not adversarial the
police go they get a warrant I'm when I
was a prosecutor I used to get warrant
signed by because ex parte but instead
of just doing that what they're doing is
they're having constitutional rulings on
the constitutionality of this data
seizure program in secret without the
companies that are actually having their
data seized be represented it's not
adversarial and the opinions that
they've written to justify it
they're also secret so we don't even
know on what basis these have been
everything the constitutionality in
secret yes yes we just found this out
maybe other people knew about it but I
just found it out and then I wrote this
piece because it seems like it violates
the due process of law so we have one
problem Fourth Amendment which is an
unreasonable seizure of mass quantities
of data from private companies that you
do business with on a contractual basis
and the other one is secret courts
passing upon the constitutionality of
the program not individual searches but
the whole program in secret in secret
opinions and that's a violation I think
that's a trail it's a serious due
process clause problem it's not the due
process of law to have not non
adversarial secret proceedings upholding
these programs how do you unpack that it
feels like there's been since basically
the modern national security exception
was created in the late 1940s after
World War two based on whose air force
case was an airplane case of some sort
there has been consistent deference to
the executive branch on issues of
national security there's no question
and in fact I have no III haven't really
thought about legal challenges that
might actually work but the first thing
we have to do is make up our mind
whether these things are appropriate or
not just that so we think we know
whether they're appropriate or not
because you know you know in wartime
signals intelligence is something the
government does engage in and so the
fact that the government's trying to
ferret out communications from
terrorists is something that would be a
tribute associated with a wartime
exercise so we don't know it's not
automatically bad but I think I've
reached the conclusion that blanket
seizures of data of all Americans of
their telephone usage in their internet
usage this is very much like general
warrants first you search and then you
find evidence of guilt which is what
general warrants did at the
Revolutionary times it's the reason why
we have a specific warrant requirement
but that's for searching and we also
have to worry about the seizure part
other libertarian legal theorists
Richard Epstein most notably has been
making you different arguments about the
NSA saying basically there are internal
mechanisms of oversight and also this is
national security this is what we do is
right we are doing this what's your
response well first of all I don't deny
the fact that surveillance can be done
in secret and actual searches can be
done in secret but the existence of an
entire program like this is something
that if it's kept secret the public
simply cannot provide the check that
Republican governance is supposed to
provide in a Republican system
ultimately the people are sovereign and
they're the ones that have to make the
ultimate decision and if they don't know
about this they can't decide so I know
Richard disagrees with me I got a
friendly email with it from him this
morning about the about my piece
expressing disappointment that I came
out with that conclusion but saying that
he himself was concerned about what he's
learned about the secret courts passing
upon the constitutionality of it and
that he plans to say something about it
pretty soon online so I I had two major
arguments in this piece and I think I
might have gotten him on one of them the
Supreme Court term just ended I believe
I remember hearing you saying that at
least on some of the issues we're seeing
an interesting strain of libertarianism
emerging on the court and if I miss
attributed that to you I apologize in
advance what struck you as particularly
interesting in this last flurry of
decisions well what you know the Windsor
case that I had an amicus brief in it
took an interesting tack who knows
whether that'll mean anything for any
future cases you never know about that
but it took this intricate Justice
Kennedy wrote the majority opinion he
has a very strong interest in Liberty as
a value I'm not saying he's libertarian
but he's a kind of his own libertarian
and so but Liberty is at the core of
what he's thinking about and he
basically made a move that we've no
one's seen before and that is he said
because states have recognized when
states have recognized the Liberty to
marry then it's incumbent upon the
federal government there's a presumption
that the
government essentially should respect
that liberty and should give heightened
scrutiny to laws like the DOMA the
Defense of Marriage Act which infringed
upon that Liberty or restricted or made
it costly to exercise that Liberty so he
combined state protection of Liberty by
the states with heightened scrutiny of
federal laws it's not something we've
ever seen before it's not the way it's
supposed to work so it's like it's
because states have expressed this value
yeah and therefore the federal
government should think about laws that
conflict with those absolutely that's
exactly the logic of the opinion as I
say I don't know if that logic will ever
be applied in another case you never
know but it's a very if it was applied
in another case it would basically give
States the opportunity to protect
liberties and then let the courts
scrutinize the genuine necessity and
reasonableness of federal laws that
interfere with that Liberty anyway it
was an interesting opinion it's it's
like that you know it's like Bill Murray
says in in groundhogs day it's different
and if he says and at the end of the
movie says anything different is good
but I'm not sure anything different is
good but in this case it's kind of a
Liberty difference reverse incorporation
it's it's basically a it's sort of an
how you recognize a fundamental Liberty
I mean he's not using the traditional
framework he's not using the standard
framework but and and it's not clear how
serious this doctrine is whether this is
a doctrine that's only going to be used
for this case because this result
avoided the court having to strike down
or say that same-sex marriage had it was
constitutionally required throughout 50
states and there were not five votes for
that so they basically wanted a way in
which they could in a sense up whole gay
marriage where it was where it's
currently recognized and not impose it
on states where it wasn't well this gave
him an opportunity to do that and so I
don't know if he'll use it again but
it's a move we haven't seen before and
it were used again it could it's kind of
it's got a libertarian it's quality to
it on this the Roberts Court in
particular has gotten pretty decently
high marks on protecting speech anything
in this most recent flurry of cases that
you see is a I don't know that we had
trying to think now I just did my
supplemented I put any speech cases
freedom of speech cases in my supplement
I now I can't remember me maybe I did
I'm in Vegas man so it's like don't
expect me to think such serious thoughts
but I mean obviously they are very
skeptical about regulation of political
speech which they should be I mean this
was a huge mistake that the Supreme
Court made by allowing Congress to
regulate the speech by which people get
elected to Congress and by which people
get elected the president they've been
doing it for years and years and years
and this court there's five justices or
a skeptical of this they keep cutting it
back and cutting it back and undermining
and undermining in this gradual way that
they seem to like to do and that's the
movement in the positive direction and
since I think they do so many things I
disagree with I certainly want to
commend them when they do something that
I think is good it's great Randy Barnett
thank you so much for joining us this
pleasure to be here at reason and for a
reason TV I am Matt Welch